Republicans must acknowledge that not
every dollar spent on the military is
necessary or well spent hi I'm Zack
Weiss Miller with recent TV we're here
at the Republican National Convention
outside of the convention floor after
senator rand paul gable speech which
mostly stuck to the convention theme of
we built it but did include a few hat
tips to the Libertarians including a
subtle reference to his father ron paul
and some mention of civil liberties
issues and defense spending we're going
to talk to some romney delegates and
some ron paul supporting delegates to
see what the reaction is and what the
future of the ron paul movement within
the Republican Party might be like
totally emotional over it it's
incredible to see that there's actually
somebody out there a Republican spouts
the ideas tonight ill and bring our
troops home and leave on it in the
Federal Reserve Family Values I love
Rand is awesome I like how he kind of
called all the Republicans that we need
to make some military cuts because I
think we should bring all our boys home
bridge do you think there's a future for
that kind of republicanism in the party
we are the future the Ron Paul
revolution is the future of the
Republican Party I don't know what kind
of depends catching was talking about
but to me I would only want the waist
cut and I don't think we can make any
arbitrary cuts I mean I think any large
organization can have efficiencies but
we should do me nothing that weakens our
military in any way shape or form they
had told him from what I hear that he
was not to say the name Ron Paul and he
was not to say my father so he talked
about his grandfather's son he would
even live
from Texas run for the presidency of the
United States that was genius that was
great I think there's a time for
everybody to have their opinion in the
primary process okay we did that for
several months okay we now have a
nominee so if you're not a Republican
supporting our Republican nominee then
maybe you belong someplace else we are
the future of the Republican Party and
whether or not the older generation
likes it we are coming in do you think
Rand might be able to merge the two
coalition's the Ron Paul coalition and
kind of the larger Republican Party is
he the bridge between the two I'm not
sure because he doesn't agree with it
with his father on things but you find
him acceptable as it as a Republican
yeah i know i still like Rand Paul I
think he's caught between a rock and a
hard place that's his father he respects
him he's honors him but it's sometimes
it's not helping him he paraphrase the
famous Ben Franklin quote we must never
never trade our Liberty for any fleeting
promise of security you think that's a
message that's going to resonate with
the Republican Party oh I guess it's
definitely going to resonate you need to
go to one of the Ron Paul rallies or go
visit ran Senator Rand Paul and you'll
love very quickly that the youth are
motorized and they're energized and they
want new leadership retired the same old
same old you the individual or the
engine of America's greatness thank you
you